Okay.
Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
April 16th,
2018 what's going on?
How,
how's it going,
man to do? You're on the
other side of it, Huh?
You paid your taxes.
You know Barb,
Barb and I blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. Hey, take more than I make.
Who the fuck are my, I just did the
fucking job. Let me give it to you.
You're rich content.
What are you going to spend it on?
You have a dash and Douche bag. Uh,
that's what do you know something?
That's what really gets my freckled
fucking goat about paying taxes.
I got no problem given these fucking
douchebags the money. I get it.
Being a citizen of a, of a country.
It's like cabin a membership.
All right?
You want those fucking potholes filled?
Yay. What pens and pencils
down at the fucking school?
You want the red light and then the green
light. Did All the light bulbs changed?
You got to pay your fucking taxes
so I don't have a problem with it.
The problem I have though is when they
get more than I get and I did the fucking
job. How did you make more
off my gig than I did?
And I was the guy up there fucking,
you know, dancing around, you know,
going down to one knee in
the end. Like fuck it, Elvis
wrapping up,
singing his truth is marching on.
MMM.
I don't get that part. I mean, I do
get it. I do understand that, you know,
we have a lot of expenses in
this getting this country.
We've got a lot of expenses. You know
what I mean? We were, we had, we had 50,
we've got a 15 year road trip that we're
still paying for right now going on 16
years, 16 years, because a
16 year fucking road trip.
I'll tell you what freaked me out.
Um, I did the rough and rowdy,
which was the fuck one of
the great experiences I've
had since getting into the
business of show. Uh, but
at the middle of it, uh,
Dan, big cat cats looked at me
and said, we just bombed Syria.
And my first thought was not like,
oh my God,
we're at war because that's been the
natural state for the better part of two
fucking decades.
My first fucking thought was,
how the fuck are we going to afford that?
We're going to start another
war and how are we going?
How are we going to pay for this?
Right.
This is like when you watch
and your friend at the
blackjack table go and, dude,
you got rent to peg. Come on,
it's over. Cards are cold.
Let's go back to the
room there. Um, you know,
some day you want to buy a house.
Uh,
but fortunately I guess we didn't start
a war. This was more like a drive by,
you know,
we,
we did a drive by with France
as far as I can tell because,
uh, you know, one of them before I get in
over my head, which I think I already am,
I mean,
is there anything better than listening
to somebody discuss foreign policy who
doesn't even have the decency to watch
the news? Whatever the fucking news is.
Now, you know, I was reading this
article in rolling stone. Oh,
I'd read a little bit this
week, believe it or not. Um,
I read this article in rolling stone
above Facebook and the influence that it
had on news,
like inadvertently and all this shit.
And uh,
and how they allegedly have,
like when you click on an
advertisement on Facebook,
like they turned some fucking camera on
and they take a picture of your face and
they try to read the expression of your,
of your face and try to gauge the level
of joy that you have to determine which
ads you're going to see. And, uh,
the only thing creepier than
that to me is people like,
do what do I k and all that kind to
figure out like what I want to buy.
Okay.
Does it just as a fucking like human
being that doesn't freak you out that
somewhere, you know? I know they're
not sitting there looking at it.
It's some fucking computer
computer instead of punching.
It's an absolute random gag. Um, I dunno,
I just don't see any of this
going anywhere. Good. All right.
And then they're going to like in this
fucking unbelievably efficient way,
get you to buy something
else that you don't need.
So then you got to throw something else
out in your house that then ends up in
that swirl of fucking trash. And
it's just like, it just doesn't,
it doesn't need to happen. So, um,
I say that as,
I just clicked on something the other
day about ready to buy yet another snare
drum.
And I'm not even in a band.
I don't have any recording sessions
coming up. I just, I don't know.
I've been trying to walk away from it,
but I,
I keep thinking about this
snare drum and I don't know,
I think a part of the problem why came
out with the fuck I was going to look up.
I'll why,
why did we bomb Syria?
This is, this is how I
learned about us. Okay.
I'm going to click on the first thing,
the U s bomb to punish it for a
chemical attack. That's what I thought.
US bombing Syria in Russia's response.
You know,
Russia is in America. We act like we
used to date. You know what I mean?
So then when we had a bad breakup,
so mad at what anybody when no
matter what they do, we'll look to,
and then they do the same thing.
I'm a God. He says, David,
I can't believe I wasted time getting to
know that person. During World War Two,
the United States along with Britain,
Britain was there to Johnny gets
show and France bombed Syria.
Does anybody in England
ever say jolly good show?
I've been to France like two or three
times and I'd never heard anybody go all
whole, whole, all right,
bombed Syria on Friday night,
Friday night. You know, let's, let's kick
the weekend off, right? That's Bob Syria.
The decision to strike came one week
after Syrian President Bashar Al Assad.
That's like a fucking number one
draft pick name. Like a wide receiver,
except for the first thing you know
like Tayshawn al-Assad dude.
The guy ran like a fucking
four one 40 we just signed him.
I'm telling you right now,
guarantee calling you right now.
Put it on your fantasy team.
He's going to get,
get at least 1500 fucking yad this season.
All right.
Use chemical weapons against
civilians outside of Damascus.
I believe that's the capitol killing
at least 42 adults and children.
After that attack,
President Donald Trump promised to
exact a big price on the Assad regime.
The US and its allies deliberated
a response over the following week.
What are we going to do? And
again, you want to fire bomb, uh,
economic sanctions.
What he say a three to
seven missiles maybe,
um, including one on the outskirts
of, okay. And then on Friday night,
the country's hit three targets, including
one on the outskirts of Damascus,
all related to Syria's chemical weapons
program or research center store.
Uh,
our storage facility and an
equipment facility and command post.
Wait, they said we hit three targets.
They just listed three a for me.
Research Center,
a storage facility and an equipment
facility and command post.
Oh,
I don't fucking know. The map of
Syria shows the targets hit on Friday.
The strikes hit at the very hat of serious
chemical weapon program and Delta a
serious blow.
All right.
As fucking weird man. So
we did that and, okay.
And I guess that makes the world safer
somehow. I have no fucking idea. I don't,
I don't understand how kids, but my
husband has made my, here's my question.
All right. Cause God knows I
don't fucking pay attention.
What if serious somehow poisoned our
food supply or cook to our economy?
You know
what the fuck are we are started a heroin
epidemic. What the in this country,
what will we do to them?
Why don't they do a drive by on some of
these fucking assholes who are allegedly
American Airlines, American citizens?
What the fuck they doing here?
Is that ever going to happen?
Fuck No.
Because those cons donate to
the politicians campaign funds.
So everything they do,
it's like it never happened.
Yeah.
And then they also advertise on
these g so called news networks.
So they never talk about this shit.
Right.
But if all freckles goes down
and tells the Rog me to joke,
all of a sudden I get in trouble.
Okay,
this is the world we're living in.
I'm going to keep asking questions.
My voice will keep going up higher.
You know what series biggest problem is?
It's not that they used chemical weapons
is that they didn't buy advertising on
CNN and Fox before they did it and
donate it to the standing president.
Be He a Democrat or a Republican.
And I am saying he,
because there's never been
a oh man as president,
you know,
and I'll tell you right now,
as long as they keep bringing women
around like fucking Hillary Clinton,
I don't think it's ever going to happen.
Okay?
You got to have some
level of warmth to you.
You can't come out there with an Al
Gore smile with, with the fucking, uh,
w with the Mike Dukakis.
Look on you face thinking that you get,
you're actually gonna win it. Yeah.
It has nothing to do with your policy.
All right? You got to come out there,
but you got to look relaxed, you know?
Okay.
You got it. You got to, you gotta
a, you look like you're comfortable.
Okay.
He can't look like you're in way
over your fucking head. You know,
having that look on your face, like, do
they like me? Do they really like me? Um,
okay.
I don't think there was anything more.
Donald Trump's scowl was as terrifying.
Is the Hillary Clinton does
that and maniacal fucking smile.
Okay.
Well it was just like,
I can't like just imagine,
imagine you're hanging out with Hillary
Clinton and you tell a joke and then she
smiles the way she fucking smiled.
You would just be like, oh my God,
I think this person is going to bury an
ice pick into the side of my neck. Yeah.
And then Trump,
it would be over there while I look at it,
but that look on his face. I, I still
can't believe one of them want it. Well,
we came down to those two,
but we did
okay.
But we did.
And the comedy and shoes out of me.
Why am I talking about foreign policy
for fucking 11 minutes when you know what
I did this weekend? I went
to Charlotte, North Carolina.
All right. And I went to the
third installment of the bar,
still rough and rowdy. A tough man
competition. And I'll tell you right now,
I have,
I don't think I've had
okay.
That much fun at any
fucking show business gig.
Yeah.
Since I can remember.
Okay.
Um,
I want to thank David Portnoy and a dead
cats full me sit there and run my Yap
for four glorious hours,
over 40 fights. Dude.
Somebody would get knocked out and it
was just like get them out of here and
then someone else would go in every fight.
There was a couple of boring once.
Um, but other than that,
every fight was great.
And if it wasn't a great fight,
it was a funny fight.
Like when you'd get to fatties in there
and eventually they would get gassed and
the fight would just start
going into slow motion.
I don't know why I didn't think to
start commentating in slow motion,
like slow my not slow motion.
So my voice down,
up to the roach,
I literally couldn't talk that slow
and kept up with the action. But um,
all right. I got to give a
shout out to the, the fight.
There was three fights to me that uh,
maybe even more than that,
my top five fights in the
night, I would say. Uh,
okay.
All right. And in no
particular order, all right.
I would say the Milkman,
his dude went in his whole promoed,
he was dressed as a milkman
drinking milk and it was just like,
what the fuck does that
have to do with anything?
And then he gets in the rank proceeds to
beat the shit out of the other guy and
the guy gets a standing eight count,
if I remember correctly.
Now don't hold me to this.
There was over 40 fights and
after the standing eight count,
this dude came running across the ring
like Tyson did in his early days when he
threw that overhand right.
Like he was trying to throw somebody out
at the plate from the warning track and
hit that dude who looked like fucking
geese Osby from the globe trotters.
Like he literally thought he killed him.
This dude did the same thing,
ran across the room except did the,
the inexplicably,
he threw an upper cut with no lead jab,
nothing to set it up. I said, well buster
Douglas do that one time. He got half,
we led with an uppercut. It got
drilled in the face and that was it.
Then that the night was over.
I'll never forget this guy goes,
you never lead with an uppercut.
Well the Milkman proved that theory wrong.
He ran across too.
He did a running upper cut,
if I remember correctly,
and just not this guy the fuck out.
And then I understood why he was called
the milk bet cause the milkman always
still livers.
Isn't that a nice story is a great story.
And in there there was head
trauma somewhere in that
story. That was head trauma.
All right. Then, uh,
the dude who came in after the main
event dressed as the pink power ranger.
This guy went in dressed as a pink
power ranger, five foot nothing,
a pink one Xeon with little red sneakers,
like the kind of sneakers that, you
know, people who embrace being a nerd,
where now and for some reason they don't
get the shit kicked out of him like
they did when I was a kid. Instead
they get glorified, you know,
is a nerd power.
It is.
So he goes in there dressed as the pink
power ranger and proceeds to take like
19 or 20 jabs to the fucking
nose until he's bleeding.
Just basically got his face red.
He didn't get the shit kicked out of him,
but he got fucking knocked around.
So at the end of the fight,
the post interview fight, he's standing
there with his nose fucking bleeding.
I just shy of profusely
and they're doing the interview
and they said, we got to ask,
why did you come in dresses? The
Pink Power Ranger, I'm sorry,
I don't know the character's name.
Why didn't you come and dress
as the pink power ranger?
And the guy just with a straight face
just goes, because she's a bad ass bitch.
I fuck her any day of the week.
I Dunno if the kid understood how
funny if he understood our folly,
what he just said was the
way he delivered it. Uh,
I would say that that's the
next great comedic minds
in Hollywood because it was very Andy
Kaufman stabby nose bleeding and the way
he said I'd fuck already day of the week.
He said it like the actress that plays
that pink power ranger would be thrilled
with that opportunity. Like, oh my God, I
could fuck this guy any day of the week.
[inaudible] the whole window
of opportunity just to
open. I, I to the point,
I'm almost dizzy with my new options.
Uh,
the thrill ride against
the Bavarian Hungarian,
the German versus the American,
which all night long people were
in the building chanting USA, USA.
Anytime anybody came in,
if you wore sweatpants,
if he had on a sports bra or whatever
the fuck you had, a Bandanna,
anything that had old glory on it,
people would start chanting USA, USA.
Even if the other opponent was also
from the United States of America,
a thrill ride lost a unanimous decision.
I thought it should have been a
split decision. Um, but he, he,
he fought a great fight
and the German one,
I'm just a fucking monster of a man.
That was a great fight.
And,
uh,
and then lastly was the frat boy versus
the blue collar kid and you know,
you think the blue collar kids going to
fucking come in and they're just like a
Hollywood movie and show
this rich so and so.
You know what a fucking knuckle sandwich
tastes like or whatever the fun and
that's not what happened. The frat frat
boy kicked the shit out of the guy.
Like the guy had no fucking
answers. And then, uh,
a fucking, the frat boy threw a
left and he must have missed any,
he separated his shoulder look like,
and then he grabbed his shoulder
in a backup and they got the video,
he popped it back in himself,
like fucking a Mel Gibson in lethal
weapon and he wanted to continue,
but ref was like, he can't continue.
So then the blue collar guy one,
yeah, I don't even think, I don't
know anything. He landed a punch.
So in the post fight, the
frat boy, his fucking pissed.
He's got all his frat buddies there and
the blue collar guy talked all this shit.
Oh yeah,
you're bringing all your frat buddies
where they're not going to be in the ring
to save you.
It's just going to be you and me and I'm
going to kick the shit out of you. Well,
the frat kid didn't eat all his friends.
They'd beat the fuck out of that guy.
And uh, and the post fight, they were
interviewing the Frat kid going up.
I must say it's a tough loss.
And the Frat kids going,
I didn't lose a beat the shit out of him,
which was true.
And then the interviewer just kept
going. Yeah. But you know, but you lost.
Yeah. But you lost, he kept
going. Yeah. But you lost.
And I saw at one point the Frat kid
consider punching the interviewer and the
face and I was actually
nervous for the interview,
or thank God the Frat kid
didn't do that. And, um,
then a special mention would
be the guy who came in,
he looked like an angry version of
the lead singer from Maroon five.
And he came in and in the first
round did not throw one punch,
just put his gloves up on either
side of his head. And we were like,
what the fuck?
This is like,
like El Pres seemed like he
was getting upset, you know,
like when Dana white gets mad cause
someone doesn't put on a fight,
the crowd was bullying and all
of this shit. And then, uh,
the comes out for the second round and
he kind of looked over in our general
direction but not quite at us. Smiled
and winked. And I said, Oh shit,
he's doing the rope a dope.
He just let this guy rock 'em
sock 'em and tire himself out.
And then he went back out there and
started doing the same thing again.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is he doing?
But then eventually he started
throwing punches. There are three,
one minute rounds and by the third round,
you know,
he'd thrown quite a few punches and
landed quite a few, but I still,
I thought the other guy was
a clear victory for him and
the judges came back and
they gave it to them. Maroon five guy. Um,
so there's a little bit of controversy,
but um,
anyways,
when I was sitting there fucking ringside
about rate to announce boxing matches,
you know,
this is something that I actually,
it's one point in my life I wanted
to be a sports announcer. And, uh,
before I realized that it was a lot of
work and uh, I had no idea how to do it.
So I just was like, well, I kind
of get in trouble for making jokes.
I'll just become a comedian. How about
that? Well, I was sitting in this,
that fucking ring,
the civic center there,
whatever the hell it was and
it looked like early eight.
The crowd looked like an early
eighties wrestling crowd.
And when they all started chanting
USA, USA, I was just like,
this is so fucking surreal right now
to be with this level of stupidity,
to be sitting in the middle of this.
I like,
this is the type of shit.
And I'm not saying that I'm
smarter than these people all,
I just haven't been around that level
of stupidity since I was the peep,
the average age of the
person in the crowd.
And I would go to event like
that and I would chant USA, USA,
would you like my credits?
I went to a live taping of Morton Downey
jr show and was screaming and yelling
and standing up and applauding.
I saw dice clay in 88 at
the Worcester Centrum and,
and with the crowd, we all tried
to bu the opening act offstage.
I booed and other standup comedian
before I was a comedian. Um,
and common came back to bit
bite me in the ass, you know,
when I fucking did that Philly show.
So I've been there and uh,
to be in an event like that, a tough man
event when everybody was chanting USA,
USA was so fucking surreal.
Um,
and I just pictured all these fucking,
you know,
all these liberal people fucking being
disgusted with it and it just struck me
as really funny and uh,
I dunno,
it took me back to,
I hadn't thought about,
I actually had to look the guy's name up.
Unfortunately Morton Downey jr I
couldn't remember his fucking name,
which is another reason why I'm so happy
I got married and had a kid because
that guy was so god damn famous and I was
such a huge fan of his in somewhere in
the back of my closet.
I still have a sweatshirt from that
go to the Morton Downey jr I got that.
I got up, this is what I did in
the 80s I went to that. I have a,
a bud man hoodie.
Do you remember when they used to have a,
a superhero for Budweiser?
I have that and I have a
Stevie Ray Vaughan tank top.
I didn't get to tee shirt. I got the
tank top because it was the eighties,
and I wanted to show off my pasty guns,
you know,
cause nobody did squats. Everybody just
did upper body in the eighties, uh,
from the instep Tor. Uh, that's what
I have left from the fucking eighties.
But anyways, um, I came in with
a fuck I was going with that,
but it was, it was amazing.
And I want to go back
to that venue and I want to do a stand up
show in the round, in the middle of it.
That's how much I enjoyed
performing there. Uh,
I mean actually announcing that
it's how much I enjoyed the arena.
So I want to thank everybody
that came out. Once again,
thanks to everybody at Barstool,
if they'll have me again,
I would absolutely in a heartbeat I would,
I would, I would do it again because a,
that was just my first one
and I think I was funny,
but I think I could be a lot funnier.
I just had to,
it was just a lot of shit to take
it. It's like, what do I do here? Do.
I actually announced the fight. I
don't know shit about fighting. Right.
Do I just try to be funny?
And then I also had to figure out how,
you know Dan, Dave worked so I
wouldn't be in the fucking way.
So I kind of,
I thought towards the end got funnier.
So we'll see.
We'll see if I get an a,
if I get another shuttle I
would definitely do it. And
you guys, she got to fight.
You know, I want to thank everybody that
ordered it too, cause I think they, uh,
I think that was their best one as far
as, as far as what I heard. Anyways,
let me read a little
bit of advertising here.
A dollar shave club.com everybody,
oh,
get rid of all that junk that's lying
around your bathroom. You fucking lunatic.
Give it the cleaning it deserves and that
freshen up with high quality products
for dollar Shave Club, dollar shave club
members. You know what you can get here.
Well you can get everything you need
delivered right to your fucking door.
Dollar Shave Club has razors shave
butter shampoos for your pubes bodywash
toothpaste. Everything you need to
look, smell, and feel your best.
You'll get an amazing high quality shave
every morning using dollar shave club's
executive Raisa.
Dr Carver's,
easy shave five goes on clear so
you can see where you're shaving.
Can somebody please
explain that detail to me?
It goes on clear so it's see through so
you can somehow see what you're shaving.
Maybe it's shiny.
Does it glisten anyways and since dollar
shave club's delivers everything to you,
and I'd have to set foot in a store,
wandering the aisles, hunting for razors,
getting caught, looking at some
soccer moms, tits. You know,
I've got to look for shampoo.
What aisles the bodywash and
where the hell's the toothpaste.
He can take all of that and throw it away.
None of it clean up your bathroom and
your morning routine with dollar shave
club's daily essential status set
for just $5 with free shipping,
you'll get the six blade executive razor
plus trial sizes of this shave body
cleanser and one wipe Charlie Oh Charlie.
Then keep the blades coming
for a few bucks a month.
Speaking of next month for a limited
time only used code Berbee you are
are@thecheckouttogetfivedollarsoffyoursecondmonthoftheclubgetscoldburratdollarshaveclub.com
to say $5 off your second month.
Join the club today,
there and lastly,
but not leastly are old friends.
The cornerstone cornerstone of the
advertising here on the podcast,
stamps.com stamps.com
saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer and
my printer and the mail mail carrier
picks it up.
They switched that from mailman.
These to be a mailman and I'm sure some
woman who walks to the beat or drives a
jeep bitched. Hey, I'm out
there too. Just to let you know.
Sorry Sweetheart,
I'm not sure sweetheart.
Whatever the fuck I have to say to
end the conversation. Sugar, tits,
a male, the male person, the mail
carrier,
patient number one picks up everything
from postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps.com account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease and
no long term commitments. Click print
mail and you're done. That's it.
Oh, it's so convenient.
Good Lord. Is it easy?
You know it's reliable
and dare I say efficient.
I used all the adjectives they want to
be to use stamps.com we'll even help you
decide out of the fucking the best place,
best class of mail based on your needs.
I use stamps.com when whenever I
send out my poster, which by the way,
I'm taking the photo today for my tour,
which is simply called 50. You
know why? Cause I'm a rap fan. No,
because I'm turning 50 in June.
Um,
I'm going to send out all my posters.
I use stamps.com and I could do when
I do it, I am a moron if I can do it.
So can you, all right? I don't care
how many math classes you flunked,
like make this no math involved.
Yeah.
And right now you too can enjoy it.
You just take the thing,
you put it on the scale, it figures
out what it was, then you're typing,
you're stupid. Does Zip Code. It's going
to and magically it gives you the answer.
It's like sitting next to a smart kid
that's not covering up his fucking test.
Okay,
and right now you too can
enjoy the stamps.com servers
with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeofbirdthatstamps.com
enter
bar.
Do you remember when you try to look at
some smart kids fucking test and he'd
cover it up?
You know,
and he'd get mad at them because
they did the fucking work.
I don't know where I stand with that.
I used to hate it when I was in school,
but now when I think about it,
the fact that that person did the
work and then I just want to show up.
I mean,
it's very,
the very least I could have offered
the kids something like, Hey,
I'll buy a buy an extra bag of chips at
lunch or some shit. You know what I mean?
Or whatever the fuck you want.
Yeah.
What, whatever. Whatever they used to
sell. They're right. All the junk food,
that's all they had was junk food.
They had a shitty meal and then they had,
it was like cookies, potato
chips, just a bunch of shit.
And I remember like for lunch
sometimes if I didn't like the lunch,
I would just take my lunch money and I
would buy all junk food and people would
say, dude, you're going to get a bunch
of Zits iffy like dad. And I was like,
I don't think I'm gonna. You
know, what am I going to do?
Have an apple and then get bullied.
He's eaten an apple, you know,
insert a homophobic shit after that.
All right,
let's talk some sports here.
Now I know this is a weird time
for most people in most cities.
Your hockey and your basketball team
are done for the year and now you're
looking at your baseball team,
but when you live
okay
in the city of champions,
or at least you were from there and
nobody won a championship until you left
like me. Well, the Celtics and the
Bruins went to when I was a little kid.
I don't remember. Although I did have
this little Bobby your sweatshirt.
My mother saves everything. I got
to find that thing. Oh my God.
That would be great.
Find that thing.
Put It on my cute little daughter. Take
a picture. Oh God. I got to find that.
Anyways. Um, if you live
in the city of champions,
not only did your basketball team
was 17 championships when it,
y'all hockey team was six
Stanley cups also one,
well maybe made it to the playoffs.
Let's start.
Let's start with the Boston Bruins.
They're up two games to none against
the original six Toronto Maple leafs who
are trying desperately
to end a 51 year drought.
I am a fan of the Toronto Maple leafs.
If the Toronto may police get bias,
I will root for them.
Okay.
I would like the suffering
to end in Toronto. All right.
I would also like us to beat them. I
want us to beat them first. However,
if they do beat us, then that will be
my team. All right. Having said that,
you got your acids quit in the
first two games of this series.
I mean just, it was easy. I mean I,
I'm not going to say it was the
first two periods of game two.
We're a little shit, little scary
period. One of the first game,
you know,
that 51 when he did that,
that fucking slap shot
from the fucking Blue Line,
that laser that hit the crossbar.
I was thinking like this game can turn
at any second and I kind of felt that way
for a lot of the second game.
It just never did because we have a guy
named David Pasta, knock on our team,
who's I would say at this point is
just shy of becoming a superstar.
The guy's got nine points in two games
he's making. It's so ridiculously easy.
He fucking scored the last goal.
He put the puck between his legs like
he was fucking around before the game.
Ooh,
right.
They should have been glove Tara music.
That's the second globe trotter
fucking reference. Yeah,
in the same podcast. Within a half
hour, 31 minutes. 32 minutes. Excuse me.
You find another podcast out there that's
going to bring up [inaudible] and then
swing is, it's fucking in a false set of
votes voice getting to talk right now.
Sig Sweet Georgia Brown. Huh? You tell me,
you tell me,
you show me a podcast that does that
and I will show you a more successful
podcast. And this one, uh,
nine points that whole fucking life.
Fucking Birger rod my Sean Pasta knock
and we're playing great defense to cause,
but you know,
making some incredible saves.
She can tell right now that I haven't
watched a lot of games this year.
All I know is that the front office of
the Boston Bruins has not gotten the
credit they deserve for the incredible
rebuild that they did it. This team,
they got rid of everybody.
Oh look who's here.
Hi.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. Oh, so then what?
I have to watch my beautiful
little baby girl. Oh. Boohoo. Oh,
poor me. Okay. Come on. All
right. All right. No worries.
Yeah.
All right buddy.
Okay.
All right. Anyways. Okay.
Bye Bye. I just gotta wait til she leaves.
I don't say any bad words in front of,
um, anyway, so the vacuum ruins, uh,
we got rid of like
the whole fucking team basically.
Okay.
Other than Ciara, um, Marshawn and, and,
and Berge on,
essentially
as far as our big stars, we got rid of
Johnny boy, Chuck Ballade, Luci styles,
Sagan, Douggie, Hamilton, Tim Thomas.
We can get rid of the coach Clo Julian.
We got rid of everybody. And I
was thinking like, wow. All right.
I tried to put a positive spin on it.
I like watching a rebuild and
all of that stuff, which I was,
I watched him all this time until this
year when it all came together, you know,
but I have a good excuse, you know, you've
got the kid, what am I supposed to do?
Huh? Not go out there and
play with my kid. Course.
I got to do that. But, um, I dunno.
Where were like really young.
We're really fast
and then we still have some veterans and
then we get some other guys that have,
you know, yeah, we got some like
guys that have a plane like six,
seven years. It's just as great mix.
And then all these young kids that are
just flying around the fucking ice and uh,
I dunno what we're going to
do this year in the playoffs.
It's looking good so far, but, uh,
I am liking the future and speaking
about the feet. Speaking of the future,
the Boston Celtics,
that's what you're watching.
That's out on the court
because everybody's fucking
hurt. Kyrie Irving's out,
Marcus smarts out. And you know
what? I totally forgot about that.
Gordon Hayward kid played fucking
half a quarter of this year.
He's coming back next year. So I'm just
watching the Celtics this year too,
to see like a, as far as the
playoffs to see like Tatum rosier,
Jaylen Brown, all of these guys
getting all this, this, uh,
just quality minutes in the playoffs.
It's just going to help us in the future.
And you know,
I don't think that we were going to
get by Cleveland or even Toronto.
Toronto looks unbelievable.
But my favorite thing in the NBA playoffs
right now is the name of the Milwaukee
Bucks coach Joe Prunty. I swear to
God, every time they say it, it's like,
did they just say conti?
And I don't know why,
but if there was a drinking game that
every time they said Joe Prunty and the
broadcast that I watched,
um,
I would have been shit faced by the
end of the first quarter. Joe Prunty,
I guess. What's his face? Um, I can't
remember his fucking name either.
Jason Kidd. I don't know what
happened to him. Uh, he was there.
I don't know why he's not there. And,
uh, it's going to be great to watch.
I don't know how many games against
the boxing Yanis on Tito come.
Paul Anti-tau camp off CDC.
Um, we actually, you
know what, let me get,
let me get the proper pronunciation of
that. That was a fucking great game.
I mean, it's, it's, you can't,
as a Celtics fan not be disappointed
when you're watching it.
Seeing all our big guns
on the bench being like,
we would be kicking the shit out of this
fucking team if everybody was healthy.
Um,
Yannis on,
uh, take two compo, we say
you say this guy's fucking
pro nuns.
Cea Shun Ncaa Shun.
Here we go. All right. Oh,
Yanis himself is going to
explain. Here we go. Come on.
Oh my internet sucks.
My Internet's slow.
Wait, you got to see with a d. So I did,
but in the Greek way you saying with
the NC like answered to consult.
So I change myself. I'll give it as a
way, even going to say the last name.
Uh, whatever you or what have you got,
just say no, it's the, that it's a combo.
Not this young Auntie to come
on day two compo. You can say it with
a t of the d. You've got to love that.
The guy has that difficult last name.
He's like, Hey, I don't give a shit.
I don't give a shit.
I'm just going to be dominating the game.
That's another thing too,
was uh,
I get to watch this guy
for a number of games too.
I think he might be the next
one. You know, once Lebron,
Lebron ever gets old, I would say
this guy's going to be the next one.
It's going to be a,
well maybe it'll be Kevin Durant and then
amp as far as like the best guy in the
league. And I'm saying
that having, not really,
I don't really know shit about hoop.
You know, what the fuck am I? Why?
Why do you guys listen to,
so I don't know shit about boxing.
I'm commentating about it. I don't
know shit about foreign policy yet.
I'm talking about that.
Asking why we're not having
missile strikes on corporations.
Um, alright. Hippie music. Let's
do some reads here for the week.
We're going to do a couple of reads
here for the week. Oh, by the way,
I have to admit,
I got a,
I got to become a Jimmy Swaggart
had Billy swagger as far as my,
remember I said I was going to be vice
free 16 days and actually the final two
days in March is when I started this.
But I said I was going to be vice free.
Uh, I got to go a little Jimmy Swaggart
here. I have sinned against you.
I fucked up Saturday night.
I went out with my lady
and um,
we went out to go see some
live music at this little club,
uh, slash dive bar that we
really love going to. And uh,
we went there and he was like, come on
man, you're not going to have a drink.
You're not going to have a drink.
And I'm like, Nah, you know,
I told my podcast listeners I was going
to blah, blah, blah. And she's like,
come on. Yeah. What fucking trigger?
I said, fine, you want me to fucking,
I was really annoyed with it because,
uh, I realized how weak I was.
Do you want me to fucking
take a fucking drink? Right.
So I ordered some food and then I had
ordered a club soda with a lime and then I
was just like, if she doesn't
bring up having a drink again,
I'm not going to order one. All right. I
don't want to throw away all these days.
Right. So she finally just
goes, look, can he does,
he's just have a hit of weed or
something like that. And I was like,
I don't fucking like weed or whatever. And
she just, and I just find said, fuck it,
I'll do it.
So I went outside the place and I took
four hits off of this fucking joint.
And I hate weed. I just don't
fucking like it. And I go inside.
And what happens every time I smoke weed
is I just get sleepy and I want to go
to bed.
So I'm watching this amazing band,
incredibly musicians, and they could
also sync too, which is a plus.
Um, but sounded like a, I like, I
like you were listening to a record.
They were so good and they ended up
doing a cover of a led Zeppelin since I'd
been loving you,
um,
that led Zeppelin would
have been proud of.
And I'm sitting there in the corner
of the bar being like, hey man,
I just want to go to
bed, man. Like, you know,
I think my pillow is like my best
friend, man. And I just, you know, so,
so I blew it. But you know what, I didn't
drink and yesterday was the big tests.
Cause now that I've, I fucked
up the whole month, I feel, um,
I'm just like, well well
now what? So now do I drink?
So last night I was thinking why might as
well have a fucking drink as I blew it,
I say I don't be a pussy.
Had a couple of hits of fucking weed.
It didn't enjoy it and he came home
and you went to bed. So whatever,
I hit one hurdle.
All right,
I've jumped over all the other
ones and I'm going to keep going.
Plus Ios also sober for
the last two days of March.
So,
uh,
but I still didn't make a month then I
basically made a, was that two days ago?
14 I, I went to 16 days. I don't give a
shit. I'm going to keep fucking going.
So whatever. I blew it. I blew it, man.
I gave into peer pressure from my wife,
you know,
she always ends up
knocking me off the wagon.
The Emma one time I went a year and
two days without a booze and we were,
we were in, uh, Norway at this fancy
fucking restaurant and it had like a,
like a 12 course meal.
All these little bites kept coming
out and I was just laughing going,
we're never going to get full. And
by the eighth loan it was like, wow,
I think I'm going to Puke. And they
just kept coming and then the end,
they came out with this
cheese plate for dessert.
That's when you know you're a ritzy
fucking place in another country.
Dessert is cheese. It's like you
eat cheese for dessert. Really?
And it was says pungent stings
the nostrils, anchorman level,
fucking Cologne. But it was cheese.
And Nia took one bite was like,
I can't fucking no way.
So I started taking giant bites out
of it and she was going to cut it out.
Don't tell him you're going to get sick.
And my eyes were watering,
my nose was running.
But her reaction,
how concerned she was for me was making
me laugh so hard that I ate the whole
fucking cheese plate. And it was, it was
fucking disgusting. But in that meal,
she knocked me off the wagon.
She's done it to me a number of times.
What I'm trying to say is
that I'm sitting, she's Nancy,
but I won't kill her someday.
Um,
so anyways,
but I have to admit that I really like,
uh, you know, the mornings
are the best. I wake up,
I feel good. I work out, you know,
they just four hits a week. The next
morning I woke up, I felt like shit.
I just felt like I needed to squeegee
my goddamn brains. So, um, I dunno,
maybe she reminded me why I'm doing this.
So I,
I think I'm going to do this right through
to my birthday and then I'm going to
be on vacation. Everybody, I'm doing
it. I'm doing a show in Dublin, Ireland,
and then I'm doing, um,
Royal Albert Hall in,
um, which I can't believe in London,
England, and then denim on vacation.
And, uh, for the next 10 days
or whatever, if I want a drink,
I'm gonna drink. If I want to smoke a
cigar here or there, I'm going to do that.
And then when I come back, I think I'm
going to jump right back on the wagon.
I'm going to try that.
That's what I'm going to try to do because
I'm eating well and I'm keeping the
weight off. And uh, who's kidding who?
I became a dad real late in
life and I'd like to be around,
so I got to shut down the
party a little bit. Right.
That's another great thing about
having a kid. If I didn't have a kid,
I probably would Ford have shaved
a good 15 years off my life. Uh Oh.
But what a fun time I would
have. All right, let's read some,
let's read some of the,
um,
yeah,
some of them use some of the, uh, music.
Oh, hippie music. That's why sit music.
Some of the questions here for this week,
by the way, did anybody see the, uh,
Andre the giant speaking of
civics says the Andre the giant,
uh, documentary. You gotta check it out.
Yeah.
You got to check that out.
My favorite part was, um,
yeah,
I guess in the locker room,
the only thing they in a locker
room were wrestlers and uh,
and the referees. No one else was
allowed in there. And he would,
and Andre would always be
in there playing cards.
And what I loved was when they actually
had footage of somebody walking in there
with the camera and Andre the giant
standing up just going for God.
God Damn big foot.
That's when he had the fro.
Uh, he stood up and the person
just ran out with the camera.
That was my favorite fucking part.
Seeing a giant angry.
Usually that's a gentle giant,
but actually seeing him fucking upset.
Uh, sorry. All right guys.
Sorry about that. I'm supposed
to fucking live and up your weak.
Not Make you want to put your head down
to your desk. All right. Hippie music.
Blind spot followup.
Not original writer,
a Billy red tits.
Saw Your First Cincinnati show
with two friends last Saturday.
You absolutely killed prime burr.
This is why you're the greatest living
comedian. Ah, wow. Isn't that nice?
And he said, okay, let me take, let me
take your dick out of my mouth. Why?
Why did guys always feel like,
you know,
they get all fucking homophobic
out if they compliment another man,
they always have to say, hey
man, Yay. That's a nice shirt.
No Homo. It's just like,
well dude,
I've known you for 20 years.
I would think if you would have fucking
made a move at this point, you know,
you could just say nice shirt.
Um,
as per the most recent
Monday morning podcast,
I'm writing to seek to second
John Fishermen of fish.
As a drummer, you need to pay attention
to. You asked for start. All right,
this is it. I'm going to fucking get
into fish. You asked for started albums.
I submit a live release.
You should start with live double album
alive one or a studio circuit in 1993.
Rift rift is my favorite album.
It's a concept album. Oh, I right.
You know what I'm doing right now.
I'm fucking,
I'm going to download it right now so
I don't forget. All right, here we go.
I tuned stork.
I'm old.
I know you guys all use a cooler
fucking downloading site. All right.
Fish with a p. H. R. I. F.
T. Let's see if I can get it.
Where is it? Where is
it? Rifts. Nine 99 Bam.
Clicked.
Why
downloading? All right. There we go.
I took your advice. All
right, the picture of nectars.
Another good one would be
my second favorite covers
of all genres and covers all
genres including jazz, country,
Calypso, rock and roll. In Neo,
Psychedelia man. Uh,
according to Wikipedia,
I can't listen to psychedelic music
because this is a small part in me that
really wants to try mushrooms. And when
I get, when I listen to that music,
I always think like,
how much more intense would this be if
I felt like I could hold my in my hand a
name for neck too,
you know,
but I'll never do psychedelics because
you can't have to be home when you do it.
But now I got a kid so I can't,
I can't be tripping with a kid.
Can't do that.
That's when social services comes by and
takes you fucking kid named for nectars
bar in Burlington,
Vermont.
That's what the album is named after where
they were the house band starting off
their careers. Anyway, love your shit
and site to hear your thoughts on John.
Fishermen fish drumming to me,
they belong in music history books,
but we'd love to get Billy rowdy
red's take on it signed from Kentucky.
All right, cool. Oh, I love, I already
loved the title of this one here.
Why I need an Ar 15 all right.
All you Hollywood liberals.
Listen Up.
I asked people in the middle of the
country or just outside of Los Angeles,
which a lot of people in La specifically
Hollywood consider in the middle of
fucking nowhere,
right?
Until they have a movie premiere
and then they go down there.
We love you from Bakersfield.
Okay.
Why I need an Ar 15 I just listened to
you talk about not knowing why anyone
would need an ar 15 I did say that in
an insulting way. You country. Fuck.
All right. I'm just saying,
you know what I mean?
If like you know for home
defense is just funny to me.
It's just like how much of an asshole
are you that you need an ar 15 for home
defense that basically on it,
you're such a cunt that on any given
night that fucking hit squad from at the
end of Scarface is going to come over
your fucking fence that you need to mow
them down. You need to basically, you
know the fucking Bazooka. Anyways.
The reason I need an ar 15 is because I
have a small flock of sheep and I live
in coyote country. Coyotes, you live
in Phoenix. Coyote won't really,
coyotes won't really harm
an animal as big as a cow,
but she per goats are fair game to them.
When coyote is attack and packs,
they tend to attack in groups
of seven to 12 individuals.
Jesus Christ, the fuck to you
live. We have coyotes out here.
They've usually impacts the twos even
though I am less cause they're all in some
Hollywood diet. Most of them die of
Anorexia so that she just packs of twos.
Even though I am a fairly good shot at
trying to hit a moving target without
hitting my sheep means that
I might miss several times.
I need the magazine capacity of the Ar
15 or a similar gun because I only have
four milking use.
So you said you use,
what is a ute? Ewee s
ah, Jesus fucking Christ.
I mean this is an easy one,
but I'm not a farmer man.
Use pro none.
Ch Pronunciation.
What a show pronunciation. Here we go. All
right, here we go. It's how you say it.
Come
on.
Ew.
Did he need to do it three times?
How fucking dumb I am.
I you.
How do you say you?
You? Oh, you all right. You,
you
okay?
You all right? He did a subtle
different read on the second one.
Ew.
Oh God. What's happening now?
Sounds like I'm hungry. Oh,
50 word mistakes.
Hello and welcome back.
In this lesson I will show you 50 words
that you are probably pronouncing you
correctly right now. And I'll also
teach you how to say them correctly.
Oh, I thought you would just
say how to say I'm wrong
yet. How do you say it? Well,
we say pronounce
pronounced and pronouncing,
but pronunciation.
There's no known in this world.
It's pronunciate.
Nobody says pronounciation.
You fucking click big content
cat.
There's no og in there.
It's cat.
All right. Why? I needed a or 15 okay,
so these coyotes come down in
packs of seven to 12 oh my God.
And his use use.
Okay.
You are fucking running
around gay. I mean,
what a fucking exciting morning.
Jesus Christ.
That's like the ultimate video game.
So then you fucking
blow these things away.
And then what do you
feed them to the pigs?
Yeah,
that is it.
You know,
if you all these fucking assholes
crossfit running down the fucking street,
like they're doing something.
This guy is inside watching deputy dog,
you know,
[inaudible] bap, bap, bap, bap, bap,
do. Right. And all of a sudden he
hears one of his use going, hey,
come on over there.
Right?
And then he's got to come out there
with this fucking machine gun get.
So can you show, get some,
I'll tell you this right now.
If I knew, if I could fucking rent
a helicopter big enough and I go,
we could open a door and you could
fucking shoot him from up there.
I would fly you around your own property,
sir,
while you did this with your Fuckin ar 15.
Um,
anyways,
I need a magazine capacity of a,
of the Ar 15 or similar gun because
I only have four milking use,
use,
and I produced Pheta and Parmesan cheese.
What a good shit.
I love both of those cheeses.
Thank you for producing that so I
can eat it if I lose a single. Ew,
ew.
Ew.
That represents a significant percentage
of my income for the year. My Shit.
That's,
you know.
Okay.
All these Hollywood liberals,
I swear to God,
if you stole their fucking Yoga Mat or
threatened to cut off the fucking man bun,
I bet every one of them
get a fucking ar 15. Uh,
but they put pink bullets in it.
Uh,
my sheepdog can hold the
coyotes off for a little while,
but not forever. That's a fucking,
that dog's got heart, Huh?
Holding off 12 fucking coyotes.
That's like when Magic
Johnson played every position.
Other farmers in more Western states
need the Ar 15 to protect from mountain
lions or wolves. So when someone
said no one needs an ar 15,
I guess they think that I'm nobody.
Ah,
you're a somebody.
You make the cheese.
Why did you have to go that route?
You proved your point and now you're
trying to make everybody feel bad for you.
Oh, he wrote, I am somebody. This is
hilarious. This is like self help.
I guess they think that I'm nobody.
I am somebody and I have a
legitimate need for an ar 15. Oh,
let's clap round of applause.
That was just textbook.
How was he supposed to do?
Let those use get killed
and then little kids can't put parmesan
cheese on their fucking Rigatoni.
God bless you sir.
God bless you.
Your ar 15 and the
wonderful cheese you make,
what do you do with all the dead coyotes?
Huh?
Man, this guy's the man that's fucking
living out there. I made the first one,
the first one. Yelped when you fucking
shot it, I would feel like an asshole.
However though I would know good and
God damn well that if I didn't make the
cheese then I would be living outside.
Next thing you know,
those pack of seven to 12
would be coming at me. Right?
I'm going to take a fucking bite out of
my flat fucking freckled pasty behind.
Can't have that. Good for you, sir.
I'm glad they've that did a weapon so you
can keep making the cheese and you can
afford to keep, you know, paying the bank
or cunts. God bless you. I'm convinced.
All right girl. That's a great fucking
argument. That argument is nowhere.
You know what it is, is smart people
never take surveys. They never get on TV.
So all you get disease more on or school.
Well, one of the government
were over sudden not to be
nice to me and I needed to
fight them off.
We're therapists sixteens and their tanks.
I made it for home
protection. Uh, why I, okay.
Girl at bar used my phone
to Venmo herself, $300.
Now I don't know what Venmo is,
but uh,
this guy basically explains it
dear Billy Bass on the wall.
Um,
the other night I was at this bar with a
few buddies and we started talking to a
group,
this group of girls,
I was hitting on this one girl and we
talked for a little more than an hour.
Her friends then said they were
leaving and so before she left,
I asked if I could ever number.
She said yes and she asks him,
I phoned a porter to put in
or number or so I thought, oh,
well she's putting in her number.
I wasn't really paying attention
and started talking to my buddy.
Next thing I know she's handing
back the phone and saying goodbye.
I told her I'll text her later this
week and try and set something up.
Well, the next day I went to look
for a number and I couldn't find it.
I searched and searched,
but the number was not in my
phone as a little disappointed.
But stuff like that happens all the time.
See, this is why this guy gets late.
He shakes it off. That's why when he
fuck are you gonna do take another swing,
right? A few days later, I
went to Venmo, a coworker,
money for lunch and it might
trans in my recent transactions,
I see a $300 payment made
to that girl from the bar.
Well, now you get your current
contact info. Uh, Hey lady,
this is what's going to happen.
Either you're going to fuck me or I'm
going to get my $300 back. By the way,
you're paying for dinner.
Uh, with my money.
That bitch took my phone and Venmo herself
300 bucks while pretending to give me
her phone number.
Okay?
I gotta be honest with you if,
if,
if that was her plan the entire night
and she was nice enough to make you
then ask for her phone number. I mean,
that's fucking amazing. It's
disgusting. But it's amazing. He said,
I of course was furious and immediately
thought of reporting her to the police
and to the people who work at Venmo.
But I thought nothing will get resolved
because how can I prove I didn't send
her the money
and I easily tell your story.
Right?
Um, you got to do Sabbath. He said, Hey, I
think you've got to do something. Anyways.
He goes also, I kind of respect the
move. It's a piece of shit move,
but pretty clever. It is
pretty God damn clever. Uh,
what would you do in this situation?
Uh,
I probably just eat the 300 bucks.
Take it as a life lesson.
I never liked go after people. I just
don't, I don't do it. I'm just like, wow,
you know, I learned a fucking
lesson. I won't do that again.
He said I could try
and get the money back.
But do you think the effort and
the hassle outweighs the reward?
I think he should do it
because it's actually a crime.
She stole money from you and uh,
you know,
I dunno.
Or You just let her keep doing it and
then one day she gets caught and she
fucking goes to jail because she find me
not going to stop at this. I would say,
you know,
something considering this whole fucking
new movement of just trashing guys all
the time and always making women
out to be the victim. It'd be nice,
a little publicity out there that,
you know,
women have the ability to also
be pieces of shit. Uh, so yeah,
let's even it out a little
bit. I would go after, fuck it,
I said $300 isn't gonna make or break me,
but I do need to stand up for guys who
wouldn't be able to pay their rent if a
girl did it to them. Right. Any advice
helps and go fuck yourself. Yeah,
I'd go after, at the very least, you know,
even if you don't get your
money back just to fucking,
it's good that you got that information
out there. So there you go fellas.
When somebody says, I'll put
my number in your phone. Um,
but you don't want to say don't do that,
cause then they might be a,
and that can affect and give it to
you. Well, you know, Chaffey second.
Um, I would just, I would use this
guy's story. I always just say, well,
the last time I did this,
uh,
the woman took my phone and Venmo
herself $300 out of my account,
so I'm just a little paranoid.
So what we me give you their
number of the time. Yeah, they do.
Okay,
you're going to get me my number. He or
am I just going to go home and jerk off?
What's your, you know, whatever. I
don't know. You guys figure it out.
I'm not in this world anymore. All right.
I go to bed at like nine 30 every night.
Now. Roommate smokes weed. Hi Bill.
I really liked your podcast and really
enjoyed your show in the Taf theater last
Saturday. Jesus am, I said good shows and
Cincy. That's twice in the three letters.
First Time I see, I see a saw, a
live show and it was fantastic.
I have a problem now I'm in college and
my roommate and I live on campus and
that doesn't sound like a
problem. It sounds like it's
fucking time of your life.
We have our own bedroom and we, oh,
we have our own bedrooms and we don't
talk very often. I'm okay with that.
The problem is he might smoke
weed sometimes in the apartment.
He mentioned he smokes weed.
The first day we moved in.
I never smoke weed and I don't
know what it smells like,
but the smells came out of his,
but the smells that came out
of his room is not a cigarette.
I'm a hundred percent sure.
Yeah Buddy. That's weed. Uh,
the semester is almost over. Should
I bring it up with them? Nah,
I just get a new roommate. You said
it kind of bothered me with the smell.
We only talked once when we moved in.
I don't know what to do.
It's against the rule on campus.
Should I talk to the Ra?
Abso-Fucking-Lutely not
okay.
Not Dude.
Don't talk to the Ra.
Ra is one letter short of rat and that's
what the fuck you would be. Don't do.
Don't rat them out.
Really liked your comedy and I think I'm
the only Asian dude that went to your
show. Thank you. And
Go fuck yourself. What?
Thank you for showing up and bring
some of your Asian friends with me.
I mean with you to see my show.
Unless you're the only Asian in
Cincinnati. I have no idea. I don't,
I don't know what's goes on.
I don't do a census. Uh, no,
I wouldn't rat him out. If you're really
concerned about the Ra, I would just say,
hey buddy,
I don't give a shit that you smoke weed.
Actually I do care that you smoke weed,
but I'm not a rat so I'm not
gonna say anything to the Ra,
but it is illegal and I'm concerned
that how much I can smell it.
The IRA is going to smell it and then I'm
going to get in trouble too. All right.
Can you do a better job of blowing
it out the window or stick?
It's thicker towel underneath
the door. All right. That's it.
I swear to God I won't talk to you again.
Um,
and that sucks man.
You guys don't even talk to each other.
So the first day you came there
and you in and you were just like,
I don't smoke weed and this guy is just
like, well I'm fucking done with you.
Everybody thinks pot smokers a cool, I
don't know. This guy sounds like a con.
A neighbor drove through my fence.
Hey Billy,
belligerent,
the title sums up this email.
But I feel like I'm in
a bit of a situation.
I recently moved back into my childhood
home after being away for about four
years. Unfortunately my dad
passed away. Sorry to hear that.
But he left me the house that
he paid off in full. Nice.
How the hell did he do that?
Usually the uh,
they hit you with so many penalties and
fees that you have to put the house back
into play.
Uh,
he said the house itself is in
disrepair. Oh, there you go.
Leaky roof, bad septic lines, et cetera.
So I already have a lot to take
care of in the coming months.
Yesterday my neighbor and childhood
friend got shit faced and drove his new
truck through my fence and go,
this is some fucking redneck shit.
And got into and into the giant
oak tree in my front yard,
the fences wire. So it
was salvaged. Salvageable.
I need to go to that pronunciation
videos. South salvage, salvageable,
salvageable, salvageable,
salvageable. There it is. But I,
I,
but I was still pissed.
My other neighbor has security
footage of the whole event. Dude,
it's everybody's filming everybody now.
Can you get away with anything including
the hilarious mobile when the guy,
when he tried to pull it back,
I guess the fence and fell on
his ass against all my neighbors.
That advice,
I didn't end up pressing charges.
Although my brother who lives with
me as well did file a police report,
which is now on the drunk neighbors
record. Uh, my question is,
did I do the right thing by not pressing
charges in sending him to jail? Well,
how would you send him to jail?
I mean by the time you got the footage,
he would be sober and he
could just say, ah, you know,
I was looking down at my phone and my
baggage and I took my hand off the wheel.
Uh,
I more or less cut ties with this
guy because he's a volatile person as
evidenced by this whole situation.
He has two young children,
one in three I think recently lost
a job and has a lot to deal with.
So I didn't want to fuck
them over even more.
And he did actually fix my fence
when he sobered up. However, I,
I don't think this will be the last
time something like this happens.
Should I have sent his ass to
jail or did I do the right thing?
I mean I wouldn't have said anything.
The fact that it got up the next day
and he tried to fucking fix the fence.
MMM.
I would talk to about it.
Say, hey listen man, you know,
I don't want to get into your business
or anything like that, but uh,
I love getting shit faced too. But if
there's any way you could Uber next time,
uh, you know, cause if I was
walking up the driveway, you know,
you would have run over me, you know, I
don't mind getting hammered or whatever.
But that level of hammered and then
to drive is a little fucking crazy.
Uh, how's everything going
with the job hunting?
Ask them a couple of Nice fucking
questions and say, listen,
I really appreciate that.
The next day you woke up,
he did the right thing and
you fix the fence. All right.
Now
that's what I would say to him.
Yeah.
Okay. And then on the other
hand, I think the fence issue,
you need to look no further than the
story of the three little pigs. All right.
The Wolf went to the first house,
little pig,
little pig let me in and the pig goes,
yeah,
I don't feel comfortable with
that dude. And he said, all right,
well then I'm just going to blow this
piece of Shit fucking house over.
And that's exactly what he did.
But he's a little light
headed and the pig gets away.
He runs over to the fucking, his
other brother's house, you know,
who actually went to college, you know,
but just got a degree in philosophy.
So all he could afford was a house
made out of sticks. The wolf shows up.
He's like, hey, he little fatty,
open this door where little pig, little
pig let me in. And then the pig goes,
yeah man. You know my other brother,
you know who took shop class,
she just blew his fucking house down.
It took shop class,
but for somehow he lives in a
fucking house made out of, Hey,
I'm not fucking doing this site. Blows
that one down. And then they go to,
as you know,
the guy who majored in finance and
stole a bunch of fucking money,
he's got a brick house.
He's got a brick,
a ban him fairly.
He's might've fat fucking over old people.
You need to,
you need to put up a brick wall.
Oh Man. That would piss him off.
Somebody did that and then the next day
you put up a fucking brick wall and if
be gives you shit,
just put your hands out like why
you drove through the other one.
You,
you're going to fucking run me over
one night or hit this poor tree.
What about the tree?
The tree can't Cilia.
It's a victim of fucking drinking and
driving. He can't take you to court.
It can file a complaint, but it can't
get there. It's, it's stuck in the ground
and you got a little brick wall
between the two of you. Hey Buddy,
if you weren't such a fucking drunk,
you know, I wouldn't have to do this.
Um, other than that,
what are you going to do?
I would have my head on a swivel though
when I got into my fucking driveway.
MMM.
This is the deal. I would just tell
the guy, just say, listen man, I'm not,
I don't want,
I don't want to call the cops.
I don't want to do when he shit like
that. All right. But if it happens again,
I'm going to have to because you're
going to kill somebody. All right.
I don't, please don't put me in that
position. That's what I would say.
And then I would build a brick wall,
although I think I would deal with my
septic tank first. But you know what?
You can't take a shit if you're
dead. This is dino it. I'm gonna,
I'm gonna make you
put the priorities up there.
You're going to roll the dice that this
fucking crazy mother fucker and his
trunks can trucks going to come over
there and drop the fucking wire fence.
I think you need an ar 15 to shoot out
his fucking tires as he comes towards
your oak tree. Why don't you
talk to the fucking cheese? Fine.
MMM.
How cool is that? That guy, he
owns a farm and he makes cheese.
You know what I mean?
So rare.
Do you meet somebody that actually
has a job now that it's like, wow,
we really need that.
We need that guy that we need to make an
another fucking app that can have some
horts steal $300 from you. Oh, it's so
easy and convenient than some of the,
you don't even know. Can just
send them fucking money. Hey,
once you have her number from
the transaction, I'd call her up.
Give me my 300 bucks back. You fucking
thieving horror before I call the cops.
I get my 300 bucks back and then I
would call the cops. There you go.
That's what I would do with her at the
fence thing. Ah, am I right with that?
But I would tell them not to do it again.
All right.
Okay.
That's the podcast.
Have a great couple of days
you'd get go fuck yourselves,
and I'll check on Thursday.